- Good morning and welcome to re:Invent.
Every one of you here has
followed the advice I received
when I told my friends
I was going to Vegas.
You made good choices.
Choices which have led you
here to this session today.
At an event like re:Invent,
you have a variety of interesting
options to choose from,
but you decided to be here.
And for that we are very, very grateful.
My name is Arvind
and I will be jointly
presenting this session
with William Yap, Principal
Product Manager at AWS.
Let me first set the stage and tell you
what we're gonna talk about.
We're gonna kick this off by
discussing why we are here.
We'll share what
confidential computing means.
What are some of the workloads
that require confidential computing.
And what are the requirements
of these workloads.
We'll then proceed to
share AWS's perspective
on confidential computing
and what we have done to make
sure confidential computing
is always on for our customers.
We will then proceed to talk about
additional requirements
like enhanced isolation
and the workloads that can take advantage
of capabilities like AWS Nitro Enclaves.
And with that in the true spirit of Vegas,
you will learn that what
happens in an enclave
stays in an enclave.
(audience laughing)
We will then switch gears
and talk a little bit about AI workloads
and the requirements that have
come with these new workloads
and what we have done to respond to that.
William will then take you through
and talk about our new
capability, EC2 attestation.
We launched it earlier this year,
we are very excited about it,
this brand new stuff we're
gonna be talking to you about.
And then he'll tell
you how we have brought
enclave-like capabilities
to EC2 instances.
And then he'll dive
deeper into attestation,
tell you how to take
advantage of attestation,
how to use it,
demystify the approach for you.
And then we'll walk you
through some use cases
like confidential inferencing,
federated learning, and some others.
And then we'll close this session out
with some resources for
you to take advantage of
so you can start building
when you leave this room.
Sound good to you?
All right, let's get to it.
So why are we here?
We are here today because you
and I share a common goal.
We care about building solutions
that enable data protection.
But let's first talk about data
because just like us, not
all data is created equal.
I'm just more handsome than some people.
That's just it, right?
There's innocuous data and
there is sensitive data.
When we are talking about data protection,
we are talking about data
that needs to be protected,
sensitive data.
Now if you look at data and
you look at what we do with it,
everything we do with data
can be bucketed under three operations,
storing data, moving
data and processing data.
Everything we do can fall
under one of these three.
And data is constantly in that flux.
It just keeps moving from data at rest
to data in transit and data in use.
The mechanisms to protect data
while the data is at rest and
in transit are fairly mature.
They existed for a long
time, very well-documented.
People know how to use it
and many of you probably
use it already, I hope.
So what we're gonna focus on today
is protecting data in use.
Confidential computing is
the ability to protect data
while the data is in use,
while the data is being processed.
And that's what we are
gonna be talking about today
and that's why we are here.
We are here to learn
how to build solutions
that'll enable you to protect data
while the data is being
processed in memory.
On the screen you see a
smattering of some workloads
that require confidential computing.
It's just a few examples,
there's a lot more.
Decryption as an operation, right?
It could be decrypting,
data revealing plain text.
You may wanna protect it
if it's sensitive data.
Signing transactions, could
be financial transactions,
could be something else.
Signing is a very, very
popular workload and use case.
Tokenization.
Tokenization could mean many things,
many different things
depending on the industry,
on the vertical you're focused on.
It could be tokenizing personally
identifiable information.
It could be tokenizing financial
assets, digital assets.
The tokenization is a
workload that is begging
for protection of the
data that is tokenizing.
Masking.
Masking is another very popular use case.
Masking credit card information,
masking your name, your
social security number,
whatever it may be.
But you can see there's a
common theme with all of this.
It's the data types.
It's either personally
identifiable information
or protected healthcare
information, financial assets,
digital assets, sensitive IP models
could be a whole bunch of things.
And all of these different workloads
come with a common set of requirements.
Customers wanna make sure
that there is no unauthorized
access to any of this data
and they also wanna make sure
that only authorized code,
code that's already been
approved and authenticated
is the only one that has the
ability to process this data
while keeping their
tax surface really low.
Because we are processing sensitive data,
we wanna contain it as much as we can.
And some workloads here are
more CPU-heavy, compute-heavy
and certain other workloads
are more maybe memory-heavy
depending on the workload.
So customers want flexibility
with resources as well.
And all of these set of requirements
need to get fulfilled while making sure
we are keeping things easy to use.
So these are some common
set of requirements
that we have had to deal with when we work
with confidential computing workloads.
So when I talk to customers,
it often comes down to two considerations.
What are you looking to protect
and who are you looking
to protect it from?
The answer to what
you're looking to protect
has already been established, right?
I think we all agreed,
we're looking to protect sensitive data.
So when you're building
specialized capabilities
to protect data, it better be the case
it is for sensitive data,
otherwise it may not be worth the effort.
So we know we're talking about
protecting sensitive data.
It's a straightforward answer.
When you get into the question
of who you are looking to protect it from,
the answer is oftentimes twofold.
Depending on the workload
and the customer,
they're at first looking
to protect their content
from operators of the cloud
provider, AWS operators.
And depending on the
workload and data types,
sometimes in addition to
protection from AWS operators,
customers want to make
sure they're protecting
that data even from themselves,
from customers' own operators.
To summarize everything I just said,
if you weren't fully following it,
confidential computing is
the ability to protect data
while the data is in use
and customers want to protect that data
from us and from themselves.
That's it, that's the summary
of everything I just said,
protecting data and use.
So now let's get into looking at
how AWS addresses these considerations.
How are we making sure we
are protecting the data
from AWS operators?
Let's start with that
and then I'll segue into how to protect it
from yourselves as well.
To understand how we have operationalized
protecting customer
content from AWS operators,
we'll have to step back and understand
how we reimagined virtualization.
On the screen here you
see a representation
of what I would like to
call classic virtualization.
This is still how
virtualization looks like
in most hyperscalers,
in most implementations,
and it works fairly well.
If you look at the picture,
you have these small
white boxes at the top.
They're all customer
instances, they're your VMs.
Then you have these colored
boxes at the bottom.
Let's just say they're all
virtualization functions
that need to happen
to enable the whole virtualization stack.
And between these, you have
a full blown hypervisor.
The Xen hypervisor, which orchestrates
all of these functions,
ring fences the VMs,
allocates the resources and everything.
So now the host, in addition
to providing the VMs,
has to contend with having to take care
of networking and IO functions,
storage and device models,
and other operational functions
like management, security,
monitoring, all of that.
So you can quickly see, in
addition to providing the VMs,
there's a lot of resources
that's getting spent on taking care
of operationalizing these
virtualization functions,
which is all then being
orchestrated by hypervisor.
So when we set out on our
journey to reimagine this,
we challenged the status quo.
It's working well, but can
we do it better, right?
Because we wanted to utilize
the resources on the host
better than we were so we
can provide more VMs to you.
So what we did in that process
was start looking at how can we abstract
these virtualization
functions away from the host.
So we free up more resources from the host
to basically offer more VMs.
So we took each of the functions
that you're seeing at the bottom,
starting with networking and IO functions,
and ran it on custom silicon.
We hardened it and we
ran it on custom silicon
and we abstracted it away from the host
and it went into a
separate box of its own.
We did that first with networking and IO
and we were pretty successful with it.
And we said, okay,
let's go and start
removing piece by piece.
And then we removed
storage and device models.
And finally we came the
to operational functions,
monitoring, management,
security and all that
and removed it.
Each of these was hardened in
its own separate PCIE card.
We call them Nitro cards.
And we have a series of
Nitro cards, which we,
you know, from a mental model perspective,
which we have in a
separate box, if you will,
which implement all of these functions
in tandem with the host.
So we ended up with a
system that looks like this.
By abstracting all of the
virtualization functions away,
we were able to remove
ourselves also from the host.
Now you can quickly see if the
host is just left with VMs,
it doesn't need a full blown hypervisor
like the Xen hypervisor.
So we wrote our own, a very
thin, lightweight hypervisor
called the Nitro hypervisor,
which has very little to do actually.
It just has to ring fence the VMs,
take care of some IO functions,
allocate the right CPU
and memory resources.
It doesn't have to do
all of the orchestration
that the Xen hypervisor had to do.
So it's very lightweight,
very little overhead.
So when we developed
and deployed the system,
in addition to utilizing the
resources of the host better,
we also ended up with a system
which was more performant.
And it was more performant
because there was very little
overhead from this hypervisor.
So we are able to provide near
bare metal-like performance
with our Nitro-based EC2 instances.
But most importantly, what's pertinent
to what we're talking about today
is we created this natural
isolation between us and the host
because we removed all of
the virtualization functions
away from the host.
So together the Nitro cards,
the Nitro security chip,
and the Nitro hypervisor, which
makes up the Nitro System,
provides that isolation
by default to our customers.
So, if you are looking to
deploy a workload on AWS,
and if your consideration is to make sure
your content remains protected
from operators of AWS,
then all you have to do is
just spin up an EC2 instance
and run your workload.
You're done.
Because in AWS, confidential
computing is always on.
It's like that switch on the screen.
Doesn't matter which way you
flip it, it's an on on switch.
It's just gonna stay on for you.
And you can take advantage
of always on confidential
computing with no code changes
because it's no different for you.
All you have to do is spin
up a Nitro-based EC2 instance
and you're good to go,
and it comes at no additional cost to you.
So remember the considerations
as you start looking into capabilities
to implement confidential computing.
If your consideration is just
I need to protect my data
from the cloud provider,
you're all set with us.
It's on by default for you.
So now that's just the gist
of what this is, right?
But if you want to gather more details
about how we have implemented
the security design
of the Nitro System,
what have we done to create that degree
of isolation I talked about
and how the Nitro System was built,
we have a white paper we published
about a couple of years ago.
It's good bedtime reading,
it's 27 pages long.
So if you're really interested in it,
you know, I recommend
taking a look at that.
It gives you a lot of details
about how this was implemented.
In addition to the white paper,
there is a third party report
that you could refer to
by NCC group, which
examined the security design
of the Nitro System
and has reported that there
are no gaps in the Nitro System
that would compromise the security claims
that we made in that white paper.
We have also updated our service terms,
I think about two years ago to reflect
that there is no operator access
to customer content if you're using
a Nitro-based EC2 instance.
So that's how we have
addressed the requirement
of making sure your data remains protected
from AWS operators.
Now let's move on and talk about
your additional considerations.
What about protecting data
from customers' operators,
from yourselves?
Only when you have such
additional considerations
do you start thinking about capabilities
like Nitro Enclaves.
So let's first see why you need
the additional isolation, right?
On the screen, what you
see is a 30,000 foot level
of what an EC2 instance would look like.
You have your instance
and within the instance
you have a bunch of different users
who have different levels
of access to the instance.
You have your application
and third party libraries
you perhaps leverage
to build your application.
And then the OS.
Now, if you were to process
sensitive data in this instance,
assuming you had your data encrypted
and stored and everything,
and you're moving it
still encrypted in transit
and bringing it to the instance.
When you encrypted data hits the instance,
if you want to process it,
you have to decrypt it.
That's just how things
work at scale today.
You're gonna have to decrypt
the data inside the instance.
But once you decrypt the
data inside your instance,
you are revealing plain text
to all of the entities
you're seeing in there.
And that's really what you're
looking to protect from
when you're talking about
additional isolation.
And that's when you start
thinking about capabilities
like Nitro Enclaves.
With Nitro Enclaves you have the ability
to allocate CPU and memory resources
from your own EC2 instance to spin up
a hardened and isolated
compute environment
called Nitro Enclaves.
Nitro Enclave has no external
network connectivity.
There is no persistent storage.
There is no administrator
or root user access.
There is no way to SSH into
the enclave by default.
The only communication
channel that exists between,
from the enclave is a secure local channel
between the enclave and
the parent instance.
That's it.
That's the only channel
through which data comes in and goes.
So now if we go back to that
scenario we talked about
where you're bringing encrypted
data into the instance
and you don't want to unpack
that data in the instance,
take that encrypted data
and continue to pipe it
and forward it to the enclave,
still keeping it encrypted.
Once the data hits the enclave,
then proceed to decrypt
it within the enclave,
at which point nobody has
visibility into the data
except the trusted application
that's running inside the enclave,
which can then proceed
to process that data.
And that's how we achieve
additional isolation
and fulfill the requirement
of protecting content
even from yourselves.
Now here's the cool thing,
and in my personal opinion,
this is the coolest feature
that the enclave offers.
Nitro Enclaves can
provide proof of identity.
By doing this, you can be sure
that when you're revealing
secrets to the enclave,
it is the specific enclave
running the expected
and trusted application
to which you are revealing secrets too.
When you decide to spin up an enclave,
you're gonna build an enclave image.
And when you build the enclave image,
you're gonna get a set of measurements,
let's call it a reference hash.
And then when you proceed
to deploy the enclave,
after the enclave has been deployed,
the enclave can fetch
an attestation document
signed by the Nitro hypervisor.
The attestation document
contains computed values
about the enclave that was launched.
It includes information
about the enclave image,
the application in the enclave,
the parent instance ID, IAM roles,
and a few other things.
These are the computed
cryptographic hashes.
So when the enclave wants
to go and access secrets,
what it's gonna do is present
that attestation document
to the entity it's
requesting secrets from.
And that entity is gonna compare
this attestation document
against the reference hash we talked about
when you built the enclave.
And if the values match, that is the proof
the entity needs to make sure
that the enclave has provided
proof of its integrity
and it can now establish
trust with the enclave
to share secrets with it.
This is a high level of
how attestation works.
I'm not gonna get deeper into this
because William's gonna come back later
and talk to you about
attestation in great detail.
He's gonna show you how to use it.
But the mental model
for the new capabilities we have launched
and capabilities that have
existed like Nitro Enclaves,
the mental model is the same.
At build time, you get a reference hash.
At runtime, you get a set of hashes.
Are these two matching?
If they match, then you
know you can share secrets.
That's how we have established trust.
Nitro Enclaves come with first
class integration with KMS.
KMS is our Key Management Service.
A lot of customers who
use enclaves also use KMS.
I was talking to folks
in the audience earlier
who were inquiring about
how to manage keys,
how to bring your own keys.
So we're happy to talk about
that later after the session.
But I just wanna leave
you with the thought that
KMS is how you're going to use keys
to bring it inside the enclave
so you can then decrypt
the data we talked about.
But to do this, KMS now
is that other entity
we discussed earlier with attestation.
KMS is gonna have to verify
that the right enclave
with the right application is
asking it to share secrets.
And with attestation it's able to do that.
And what we've done for you
is integrated this whole attestation flow.
But you're by no means tied to KMS.
If you wanna use your own key
store, feel free to use it.
You just have to build
the attestation yourself.
What we've done with KMS
has made it easy for you.
That's it.
So here's a quick summary of
everything we talked about
in terms of protecting
content even from yourselves.
With Nitro Enclaves,
you achieve additional isolation security.
There's no external network
connectivity, no storage,
no administrative root user access.
And the only communication channel
is a secure local channel.
Nitro Enclaves are highly flexible.
They are processor agnostic.
So it doesn't matter what instance type,
what CPU instance type
you're trying to leverage enclaves from.
Could be Intel CPUs, it could
be AMD, it could be Graviton.
Nitro Enclaves are functional
in all of those instances.
And more importantly, bringing you back
to that flexibility we
talked about earlier,
you can choose varying
combinations of CPU and memory
to allocate to your enclave
depending on the demands of your workload.
So it could be more memory,
less CPU, whatever you need,
you can choose the combination yourself.
Pretty flexible.
And lastly, enclaves come with
cryptographic attestation,
which helps it prove its identity
so it can establish trust.
And you get all of this isolation again
at no additional cost.
If you're using your EC2 instance,
all you're doing is
dedicating CPU and memory
from the same instance
to create an enclave.
So, that's the high level of enclaves.
I'm more than happy to take
questions about it later.
We have more planned for you today,
so I'm gonna keep moving.
Here are some customers that
have used Enclaves successfully
and this is just a subset of
customers who are using it.
The reason we chose to show you this
is to give you an idea of the different
verticals and segments that
take advantage of capabilities
doing Nitro Enclaves.
So you can see that our
customers in the ad tech space,
customers in financial,
traditional financial industry,
customers within the
Web3 blockchain space,
crypto exchanges, privileged
access management customers.
There's a wide variety of
customers who can take advantage
of such foundational capabilities
to implement confidential computing.
As you go through this
week, I wanna direct you
to some sessions as well.
Two of the large payment
processors are presenting this week
on their use of confidential compute
and Nitro Enclaves at AWS.
So both Visa and
MasterCard will be talking
about real-time payments
and how they have leveraged enclaves
to build secure and low latency solutions
to do payment processing.
Coinbase will also be speaking this week
actually with me on Friday
to talk about their implementation
of secure wallets with enclaves.
It is actually a session
focused on agentic payments.
So if that's something
that tickles your interest,
I invite you to join us for that session.
And Coinbase will talk about
their use of x402 protocol
to integrate with agentic payments
and how they integrated
Nitro Enclaves-based wallet
for the solution.
There's also additional reading
on how customers like
Fireblocks have implemented
custody solutions with enclaves
and how Stripe has done
key management solutions
and Brave rewards computation solutions
using blockchain technology.
So these are all what we have already done
and accomplished with customers
and we'll continue to
work with you on these.
But now things are starting
to shift a little bit.
AI is here and with AI
there are new workloads
and the requirements that
we talked about earlier
have evolved a little bit.
With the new AI workloads,
customers want to now make sure
they're running their workloads on GPUs
and AI accelerators for the large part.
So whatever capabilities
we talked about earlier
need to be made available on all of this.
Customers want to protect the models
and the weights that
they're bringing inside
the compute entity.
Not only that, they want to proceed
to seal these models and weights to that
so they can be really sure
it is the right instance.
It's the right isolated
environment that's fetching data,
that's fetching the model.
In addition to that, no surprise with AI,
you need greater bandwidth.
So this consideration with no
external network connectivity
was starting to create
some friction points
and customers also wanted
storage, access to storage
because they need a lot more data now.
It's not just about dropping
a small payload or a few keys.
And all of this again
with no code changes.
So we started to look into this
and launched a new capability,
which William is now gonna
come and talk to you about.
I invite William to talk to
you about EC2 attestation
and take you through
the rest of the session.
I'll come back and close it out
with some resources for you later.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- I got it.
Thank you, Arvind.
Good morning.
My name is William Yap
I'm a principal product
manager for Compute Services.
I've been handling confidential computing
for the past six years.
So all the stuff that Arvind talked about
they're called Nitro.
Nitro Enclaves, NitroTPM, Nitro System
are capabilities that
we've worked on building.
And so, in this talk, I'm gonna try
to give you some of the insights
of what we were thinking about
when we're building these capabilities.
Now, Arvind mentioned AI, you know.
AI is something definitely
that's caught a lot of interest
the last few years,
but we're gonna use AI as a template,
a reference case study
to talk about the new
confidential computing features
that we've built.
And 2025 has been a busy
year for the Nitro team
and we are excited to
tell you all about this.
Generative AI is interesting
for confidential computing
because of the sheer
number of sensitive data
that you're looking to bring there,
as well as the multiple
parties that are involved.
I've simplified what it
means here for user data,
but what I'm talking
about, it could be prompts,
it could be your business
data, financial information,
personal data, things you bring through
via RAG, knowledge bases and all,
These are things that you wanna protect.
The second thing that's
sensitive is the model itself.
For close models that the
model weight represents
significant investment
to train those models.
You would like to protect that too.
And depending on the type of outputs
that you're producing,
it could be sensitive.
So as you can see, multiple
sources of sensitive data
and different parties
that's owning each of it.
And we wanna protect that.
So which when you have
multiple sources of data
that are going into the
models for inferencing,
we're seeing customers, enterprise
who are looking for ways to give stronger
data privacy assurances
to their end users.
Or if they wanna hand over their data,
what are the assurances
that we can give them?
So let's break it down.
Let's break it down into three goals here.
The first goal that we wanna
solve is we wanna make sure
at the base foundational
infrastructure level,
the infrastructure
provider has no mechanism
to access the data.
The cloud provider has no
mechanism to access the data.
The second goal that you wanna make
is to make sure that
when you go up one level,
the service provider, the enterprises
also do not have access to the data
that's gonna be used for inferencing.
And lastly, you have encrypted data
that's going into this environment.
You need a way to prove
that this environment
is what it says it is.
It's isolated before data gets decrypted,
before data gets processed.
So we're gonna tackle this together,
we're gonna work through this as a group
to try to solve this problem.
And using AI as a template,
we're gonna look at how from AI
we can look at other case studies as well.
Item number one, we solved
that pretty quickly on EC2.
As Arvind mentioned, the Nitro System
has no operator access.
It's by design is something that we have,
we spent a multi-year
investment to build the chips,
the software with the
number one design principle
to making sure that no AWS operator
has a mechanism to access the data.
Our EC2 Nitro instance is very different
from the classical
traditional virtual machines
where you get this type of protection
and that's gonna give us
a very strong foundation to build upon.
So number one checks out very
easily for you as the customer
because on AWS we spend
significant investment
to make sure that's easy.
Let's focus on number two.
How do we make sure there's no mechanism
for you as the enterprise
as a service provider
to access the data yourself?
Arvind mentioned that we needed to evolve.
Your requirements are evolving.
You want confidential computing and GPUs,
you want confidential computing
with networking, with storage.
And when we, you know, me
as the product manager,
when I look at building
this on the Nitro Enclaves,
as we add more and more
capabilities to the Nitro Enclaves,
it's gonna start to look
more like an instance.
So instead of evolving
Nitro Enclaves that way,
what we've done is that
we've taken the capabilities
that you like in Nitro Enclaves
and bring it back to the
regular Nitro EC2 instance.
And this is what we have launched.
We call it EC2 Instance Attestation.
It's a capability that makes
it easier for you to validate
that only trusted software, trusted code
is running on your EC2 instance.
You know, before this
you can definitely build
trusted EC2 instance.
You can definitely build an
EC2 instance that has no SSH.
But what you have over
here is a capability
to evidence that, to prove that
and to allow decryption of
data only when that's true.
If you notice one thing, we
didn't give it an AI name.
Just called EC2 Instance Attestation
because we see this as a way
that customers are gonna use across
all different types of use case.
We see this as something very powerful
that you're gonna use generally.
So, what is EC2 attestation?
It comprises of several capabilities
and I'm gonna talk a bit about right now.
At the base layer we
have the Nitro System.
This is a Nitro EC2 instance,
it has zero operator access.
We have this device that you can attach
to an EC2 instance called the NitroTPM,
the Nitro Trusted Platform Module.
This is something we have already.
This just follows the TPM 2.0 standards
and it does measurement,
it does attestation
for the EC2 instance.
You can do this on an EC2 instance
that has an AI accelerator.
So many of our GPU instance,
our Trainium2 has this capability.
This is the starting point.
Let's look at the new stuff.
The first new stuff that we have launched
is Attestable Amazon Machine Images.
This is a new way to build AMIs.
When you build it, you'll
get a cryptographic hash
that represents the content,
the root process of that AMI.
We're gonna dig deeper into that shortly.
Next thing that's new
NitroTPM Attestation Document.
Now you can generate the same
style attestation document
that you get from Nitro Enclaves
with NitroTPM on a regular
Nitro EC2 instance.
This makes the attestation
process very easy to do.
You no longer have to
do the multi-step dance,
you just have a document that's signed
with all the necessary information.
And the last thing that we have launched
is that we know that every customer
is gonna need to figure out
key management and attestation
and how you're gonna
have the data encrypted
and only allow decryption
when the attestation passes.
And so, we've done the
heavy lift for our customers
by integrating that with AWS KMS,
integrating NitroTPM with AWS KMS.
With these three capabilities combined,
this gives you the tools to
configure your EC2 instance
into an isolated compute environment,
into an environment you
yourself cannot get access to.
Let's dig into each and
every one of them in detail.
The first one, attestable AMIs.
It's a new way of building AMIs
where at the time you complete building
and creating that AMI, you
get a corresponding hash.
It contains a measurement of everything
you have put inside the AMI.
And the hash that you get from this AMI
is your reference measurement.
This is the true hash
'cause you know all the ingredients
that you have put inside the AMI,
you know that this is the true one
and you're gonna keep it securely
to validate against later.
Let's keep that in mind.
So, if I go back to the problem
that we're trying to solve here,
you now have an inferencing environment
where you wanna lock yourself out.
What kind of configurations can I do here?
How should I set it up in a
way that I don't have access?
Well, we do have some best
practices to share here
and this is documented as well.
And I say best practices
because it does vary
according to the type of use cases
depending on how you're
planning to use it.
But the first one, the most important one,
you wanna remove all forms
of interactive access.
What I mean by interactive access?
No SSH, no serial console,
no SSM, and the likes.
And we're not talking just
about disabling a user
access to the SSH function.
What we're talking
about is the SSHD daemon
is not even installed.
There's no mechanism at all.
First one is removing that access.
Second thing is that you wanna validate
and ensure that only trusted code
are running inside that
instance, inside your AMI.
Because you're doing highly
sensitive processing,
you don't want to install
all types of packages
that may or may not be necessary.
You wanna look at only
the necessary packages,
the only necessary tools to
be able to run that workload.
The third thing, you wanna have a network.
So since you have networking right now,
you wanna have a network firewall
within the instance boundary
to make sure you get
protected access there.
Number four, you wanna
make sure that all storage
and file systems is
immutable and read-only.
So now you have an isolated environment.
You can't get in, nobody can get in.
How do you make good use about it?
So borrowing the stuff we
did with the Nitro System,
we can look at building APIs.
Not just any APIs, build trusted APIs
that needs to be authenticated,
that needs to be verified.
It's gonna be logged, authorized
before it can be used.
And ensure because you are
the design of these APIs,
ensure that this APIs doesn't do anything
that's not supposed to
do, that's not documented,
that doesn't interact in with
customer data or user data
in a unapproved way.
So these are the five best practices
and you can put these ingredients
into an isolated compute
configuration file.
That's the ingredients.
Let's put it into a recipe.
At the base layer, you
have an Amazon Linux,
just a base image, very minimal.
You have your trusted code
and then you've got your configuration.
Now we work with an open
source tool called Kiwi.
This is an open source tool
that allows you to build images
where you can provide the recipe
to the Kiwi tool that we have
integrated with and
generate the trusted AMI
with the corresponding hash.
Now remember this is your reference hash.
This is the hash that you trust,
you provided the ingredients,
you verified the ingredients.
This is the hash you trust.
Let's keep that in mind
because we're gonna use that.
With NitroTPM, when you
launch an EC2 instance
and you enable NitroTPM,
the NitroTPM device gets attached there
to your EC2 instance
and at launch it will measure everything
about that EC2 instance.
And notice something, the GPU and AI chip
are within the protected
boundary of the EC2 instance.
When you measure it, you
get a calculated hash
and you can compare this
calculated hash of this instance,
check it against your reference hash
to see is this the instance
running the configurations
that I've stated that
have zero operator access?
If it's true, I've done it the right way.
So, before this you can absolutely
create an EC2 instance that has no SSH.
Difference here is that you
can get the measurements
and compare against that.
That's how we solve goal number two.
No mechanism for you to access user data,
the isolated compute environment.
Now we're gonna talk a bit more about
how we're gonna solve number three.
And in order to do number three,
let's go back from the beginning.
How does cryptographic attestation works?
Well, the reason why you
wanna know why attestation is,
is how do you know your
instance is truly yours?
How do you know instance I123
or instance A here has the right code,
right measurements that you have stated?
I think if you spend time
you can definitely figure that part out.
But imagine if you have
hundreds, thousands,
hundreds or thousands of instance
that problems gets multiplied.
We need a more scalable way to determine
whether this is the right instance,
your trusted instance
before you're sending
highly sensitive data to it.
For the humans, we kinda
solved this problem already.
I know most of us, we
travel into Vegas by plane.
We have to go through,
everybody has their passport
or identity card, real ID
to get over here in Vegas.
If you think about that,
an attestation document
is kinda like a passport
to an EC2 instance
or to an enclave.
Instead of a name,
instead of the date of birth and location,
you get measurements
and it contains measurements of the code
that's present on boot,
the boot up process,
all the configurations
and the passport has to be issued
by an authorized authority.
You know, anyone can just issue it.
And so, the attestation document
that you're getting here
is gonna be signed by
the Nitro hypervisor,
the Nitro System.
That is the first part of attestation,
being able to the attestation
document to produce it.
That's the other side,
another side of attestation.
How do I verify it?
Once you present the passport,
which database do I get to
make sure that the values
that I'm looking at the
passport is correct.
That's the validation piece.
And you can figure out
the validation piece
by having your service
refer to the reference hash.
Remember at the beginning
when we build the AMI,
you get that reference hash?
You can take note of that,
get your service to look at it
or to check against that.
But the challenge there is that
remember we wanna encrypt the data
and send it to the isolated
compute environment
for processing.
So it's not just sufficient to do that.
You kinda need to figure it out
and add key management
somewhere in between as well.
So borrowing what Arvind
said with what we have done
with Nitro Enclaves.
We know every customer is gonna
try to figure that part out,
so we have done the heavy
lifting for you as well.
So we've integrated
attestation with the AWS KMS.
When I say integration,
what I mean here is that
AWS KMS has the ability to
ingest attestation document.
It knows how to compare the measurements
against your trusted measurements.
You would place your trusted measurement
as just a KMS as key policy.
It will compare against that.
The other thing it does as well,
it knows how to compare that
and check the validation
of the Nitro System
that it's correctly signed.
This is the capability that makes it easy
for you to do multi-party computation
with an EC2 instance.
Now, we've look to all the
pieces that we have launched.
Let's put it all together
and look at how we can make a flow there.
And the flow is gonna be simple
because it's designed to be simple.
So if user data that you wanna protect,
you encrypted it and you're
sending it to an EC2 instance
where you have configured no SSH,
no interactive access.
You have where you built that isolation.
It goes to the EC2 instance.
EC2 instance would then send
the attestation document
to AWS KMS that says, Hey,
I'm the real instance.
Check out my configuration.
Here's the measurement.
AWS KMS takes that,
compares that against your key policy.
Compares that against the real,
your reference measurement there.
If it checks out,
it will release the encrypted data key
back to the EC2 instance
where only the EC2
instance can decrypt it.
So now you have user data
that have been decrypted.
You can process it in that
LLM, do that inferencing,
and depending on whether the
outputs are sensitive or not,
you can encrypt it and send it back out.
This is the flow
that we think is very
powerful for customers.
By the end of this week we
have, as Arvind mentioned,
we have workshops, we have code talks.
Everyone can leave Vegas with
an application that does this
and we're gonna have the
workshop online as well
if we don't get to it.
This is how we solve
the three privacy goals.
And we've made that process
very easy for our customers
by providing the combination
of these tools to do it.
Now, I promise at the beginning of my talk
that we're gonna talk more about AI.
I mean we're just using this
as a reference case study.
So let's talk a bit more about
how we're gonna look at this
and how does this vary.
In the example that I provided earlier,
you have this flow here,
you have the end user
that you wanna protect,
end user data you wanna protect,
you have the model data
that you wanna protect.
And the processing in the
middle is inferencing.
But let's say we take away
inferencing for a second here.
And instead of the model
provider and user data,
we say let's have two hospitals.
We have patient data and
hospital A and hospital B
are saying that if we can
find a way to collaborate,
share some patient data,
we can get some metrics,
we can get some information
that's gonna help with our research.
This is a piracy
preserving way of doing it
where you can encrypt the
data, send it to an environment
that neither party can get access to.
Do the processing that
both parties have agreed to
and only allow decryption
of data when that's true.
So if we've changed the
processing in the middle,
we changed the party
but diagram looks similar,
it's a multi-party computation process.
Now let's change the
hospitals to something else.
Consumer goods.
Let's say you have two different companies
that are processing user preferences.
In the ad tech space they
wanna tokenize user identity.
So instead of looking at William's
preferences for shoes,
they're gonna look at token
AVC's preferences for shoes.
The sensitive processing part of this
is a tokenization process.
Changing the name William into a token.
'Cause if I get access to
that tokenization engine,
I can reverse it, I can see it.
You wanna run that in an
isolated compute environment
in a way that neither
parties can can do it.
So we are seeing a lot of
interest in attack space.
Federated learning.
Let's say you can't send the
patient data out, you know?
Cancer centers, hospitals
sometimes have a requirement
that they can't do that.
So with federated learning
is what they're doing instead
is that they're trading the data locally,
building the models locally
and just sending the model weights out
to a central location.
The central location will be an aggregator
that combines all the
model weights together
to get a global model
where all the parties
can use and gain benefits to.
What I've changed here in this diagram
is just a number of
users and the processing.
The concept that we have
here is still the same,
multi-party computation
building the isolated
environment that neither party,
that no party can get access to.
Encrypting the data,
whether it's model weights
to sensitive data,
sending it to the
environment and decrypting it
when it's proven is to be true.
So I hope we learn the new process today.
As I mentioned, everyone
here can leave Vegas
with the new application that does this
with a confidential computing application.
I'm gonna hand it over
to my colleague, Arvind,
who will give you more resources
on how you can leverage
those capabilities.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, William.
So moving forward, let's talk about,
you know, to summarize everything
we talked about over here,
about confidential compute, right?
You heard us talk about
different capabilities
for different considerations.
We just have the Nitro System
upon which our EC2 instances are based on.
So if you're just looking
to protect from us
to spin up an instance, you're good to go.
Now if you're looking
for a very opinionated,
isolated compute environment
that's hardened already for you,
you have Nitron Enclaves.
Now if you're looking for AI use cases,
you're looking to protect your models,
you protect your weights
on GPUs and accelerators
and William talked to you at great length
about EC2 attestation,
how to use that on GPU
and AI accelerator-enabled instances.
All of this, however,
comes with a common theme
and the common theme is Nitro.
And what makes it really special
is that with any of these
that we talked about,
it comes with the assurance
of zero operator access,
no mechanism whatsoever.
And now, if you notice the
language a little bit different
from no operator access to zero
because if you're just
using an EC2 instance,
you're protected from us.
But now when you tag on the
additional capabilities,
you've also protected from yourself.
That's really how we're trending towards
that zero operator access, right?
And then as I mentioned
earlier, with all of this,
you get near bare metal-like performance
because of the way we architected it.
So between the virtualized
instances in the bare metal,
it's like a single digit
percentage difference.
Highly performant.
So very well-suited for your AI workloads.
And with the new launch,
we have now supported it
across all of our instance types.
So you're not restricted to CPUs.
You could use GPUs, AI accelerators,
any CPU if you choose to use
enclaves and all of that.
So there's a lot of flexibility
with the instance types we are offering.
And lastly, as I mentioned
with attestation,
we already ensured we are
integrating all of this with KMS.
So for most customers who
leverage these capabilities
with our Key Management Service,
it's already built out for you.
But again, you're not,
you know, bound to it.
You can always use your own key stores,
use your own external services,
you just have to learn how to consume
that attestation document
and then build it out yourself.
And lastly, with the new capabilities
that William talked about today,
we have launched it in
all commercial regions
and GovCloud as well.
So if you are working on mission-critical
applications and workloads and
you're leveraging GovCloud,
all of this is now available on GovCloud
in addition to commercial regions.
Now, if any of this piqued your curiosity
and you are looking to build more,
we do have a couple more sessions
specifically on this topic.
One is a code talk
where we will deep dive into
demystifying attestation.
We'll actually open the attestation code
and walk you through
what's been implemented
and how to use it.
And then there's another workshop
that you're welcome to join tomorrow
on creating trusted execution environments
specifically for
generative AI applications.
So we will show you how to
stand up the whole thing
with a GPU or inferencing
or retaining based instance.
I would like to thank all
of you for taking the time
to listen to us today
and come join the discussion
for confidential compute
at re:Invent 2025.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)